a new law is going into effect in
mississippi today to help combat a
growing problem nationwide the theft of
catalytic converters from cars catalytic
converters are an important part of your
vehicle's exhaust system and it's become
a pretty easy target for thieves often
reselling for hundreds of dollars carter
evans has the story
they took all this piece this is all
where the cathartic converter goes
and the oxygen sensors they're all
missing it's becoming a common sight for
mechanics and an expensive lesson for
car owners you feel violated crystal
washington had to pay 25-hundred dollars
to replace her catalytic converter after
thieves stole it in broad daylight
[Applause]
working like nascar pit crews crooks
jack up the car and use a cordless saw
to cut out the converter in seconds hey
you this man confronted thieves as they
crawled underneath his truck since
kovitz started the theft converters has
gone up like crazy from 2019 to 2021
thefts shot up more than 1200 percent
with california texas washington north
carolina and minnesota leading the
nation without your catalan converter
you really just can't drive the car
consumer reports auto reporter benjamin
preston says what makes them so
expensive is what's inside you'll have
probably at least a thousand dollars
worth of precious metals in a catalytic
converter each one can contain several
grams of platinum palladium and rhodium
which are used to decrease noxious gases
from engine exhaust and with today's
prices for those metals thieves can sell
them to scrap yards for up to a couple
hundred bucks a piece
in los angeles police have offered to
etch vin numbers onto catalytic
converters to deter theft this year
alone 36 states are working on
legislation to regulate how they're
bought and sold but in the meantime now
is a good time to start keeping an eye
on it and thinking about where you're
parking might be worth walking a few
extra blocks just to park your car in a
better place carter evans cbs news los
angeles